know how proud i am of you who you've
grown into i remember
yesterday carrying both of you home from
the hospital
i did in the middle of a snowstorm
jennifer lopez is officially
a mom to two teenagers you know in
february uh jennifer you're gonna have
teenagers
i know it's crazy it's just it goes
so fast and again that's why it's about
cherishing every day
the 51 year old triple threat took to
instagram on monday to celebrate her
twins
max and emmy's 13th birthday of course
jlo shares her kids with her ex-hubby
marc anthony
good morning good morning
it's great to stay up late good morning
good morning to you in the sweet video
jen delivers the newly minted teens
breakfast in bed
along with their birthday cards
oh yeah
[Music]
in the caption the proud mama opened up
about the day she brought them home from
the hospital
in the middle of a snowstorm writing
quote out of that blizzard came
two perfect little coconuts who
rearranged my life
and taught me the true meaning of love
it has been
the most magical journey full of
adventure and joy
ever since i don't see them and they
don't see me then
it's not happiness jennifer said she was
full of feels on the milestone day
adding quote to my two caring sensitive
and special
souls who i know will change and
rearrange the world in your own
very unique ways your mama loves you
beyond forever and ever
and ever do you know how proud i am
missing from the sweet birthday clip
jaylo's fiance
alex rodriguez a source tells et that
the kids are with their mama in the
dominican republic
while she films her latest flick shotgun
wedding
and a-rod well he's spending some time
in miami with his daughters
12-year-old ella and 16 year old natasha
quote alex had work to do and jen got
some quality time with her kids
the couple plans to do something
together for the twins birthday
when they are together again soon
everything we do is for our children
and coming together like that and and
seeing the kids how happy they get that
we're all together
is priceless in the meantime alex
celebrated the twins 13th birthday with
a post of his own which included some
family pics
and videos the caption i'm blessed to
have
both of you in my life and look forward
to watching you both continue to grow
and do amazing things keep reaching for
the stars
love you both and all that love it's
mutual
we always got along pretty well at first
i just thought mom and alex were friends
and i was like oh he's staying with us
for a really long time
and then and then um
and then i realized i was like oh
they're together and then i was like oh
ella and toshi are gonna be my sisters
oh
it was a sudden realization eti caught
up with emmy back
in september while promoting the book
she wrote called lord help me
the author opened up about drawing
inspiration from her famous mama
well my mom's just like she's amazing
she's yeah so
she's such a powerful human being it's
insane like
i don't even know how to explain it